so we've heard actually your
explanations of whether we can reduce
life to a single set of rules and values
but let's dig a little bit deeper
specifically when it comes to the forces
behind this does I suppose the first one
that I'm going to put to Sophie Grace is
does an objective morality exist that
this these rules could be based on well
um I am an objectivist I do believe that
value is real and I think value is there
as part of the way that we live together
and work together I think it's part of
the fabric of things and I think things
that often look very much like not
values for example the notion of a fact
actually it is a deeply I think deeply
normative Notions to say that something
is a fact is to Market as something that
we can trust
and so in in a sense I mean if I'm if
I'm in a knock about mood and why
shouldn't I be it's it's almost cocktail
time
um I'm inclined to say who cares about
objectivity
um it's not that we're looking for some
kind of cosmic
super existing super world
objective truth with a capital T you
know which if if Terry Gilliam was doing
the the um the graphics that'd be the
words truth inscribed in stone rotating
in empty star star-studded space what
that's not what we need even it's there
and I'm not objectivist so in a sense I
do believe it's there but that's not
what we need what we need is something
that we can trust
as the basis for our working together
and living together we I think this is a
kind of massive red herring we think we
need to go up to the Stars to bring
objectivity Down to Earth but
objectivity objective truth is already
there and it consists in our ability to
trust one another and that's one I think
that's one of the the products the
psychological products of having
um rules that we keep and are seen to
keep and I think this is where the idea
of objectivity comes together with
Simon's very interesting and um stress
on empathy because the link between the
two is trust it's behavior that we can
trust Behavior patterns that we can rely
on from each other and that also helps
us with Embassy because if we know that
people are
um at least to some extent predictable
in the way they behave because they keep
rules then that helps us to see into
their minds Massimo I suspect you will
be in full full agreement with this
notion of uh objectivity
actually no no I'm not I don't think
that series that you think is objective
morality if by that we mean what
philosophers refer to as realism that is
uh the notion that there is a truth of
the matter to uh moral questions that
it's a moral questions are analogous to
factual questions or to mathematical
questions I don't think that's the case
that was cons uh perspective for
instance that's the perspective of most
religions and I I don't I can't make
sense of it I don't know where those
those truths would would come and how we
would find out about those truths
however the the interesting part I think
for me is that just because there is no
objective truth out there in terms of
Ethics it doesn't mean that ethics is
arbitrary it doesn't mean that um that
anything goes that your opinion is again
is just as good as mine there is an
intermediate position which is often
referred to is in moral philosophy as
ethical naturalism ethical naturalism is
the notion that uh we need to step back
for a minute for a second and ask
ourselves well what is ethics anywhere
what is the function of Ethics or moral
things by the way I'm going to use
throughout ethics and morality as
synonyms so if anybody wants to make a
distinction there they're welcome but
I'm going to use them as synonyms and uh
and the question is well where does that
come from uh it comes from the fact that
we are we evolved as social animals and
we live a we need we need ways to live
together to cooperate to function uh to
regulate more or less our society and
we're not just us but other social
primates and sure enough other social
primates we've observed have developed
the equivalent of what we would call uh
Moral Moral behaviors or ethical
behaviors and so that means that the
point of Ethics is in a you know
especially in uh
Advanced Human Society meaning a society
with language and and uh complex
structure civilization etc etc is to
maximize the chances that each one of us
can flourish that is the point right now
there are many many different ways of
doing that there isn't what just one
answer that that's why I'm skeptical of
rules and there isn't there isn't only
one uh specific way of going about it
which is why I don't think there is an
absolute sense of of morality however
the results are a lot of things that
don't work a lot of things that that
undermine uh human flourishing and
therefore those things are in my book
unethical or immortal so I guess what
I'm saying is no there isn't no such
thing as universal morality or objective
morality but there are very strong
constraints that being a social animal
of a particular kind with certain needs
and certain uh priorities and desires
imposes on how we want to behave over
each other which is again the kind of
the problem that ethics tries to solve
as
I want to bring you in obviously at this
point
um where does the idea of empathy fit
into this is empathy one of the uh
objective morals that we can refer to
where does it fit into what our other
panelists have yeah yeah
um so you know if the question is
um does an objective morality exist
um I think uh I think I would sort of
replace the word objective with the word
Universal you know that what were that
often what we're trying to arrive at is
a set of universal rules for how to
treat one another and you know that's
kind of what we what we expect
organizations like the United Nations to
be there for or the World Health
Organization to be therefore and even if
we go back to my earlier example about
the Nuremberg code of ethics you know
they were trying to develop
a code that could apply to any society
at any time not just now but in the
future you know of what counts as as
ethical you know and it and it includes
details of that if you're if you're
dealing with patients or if you're
dealing with
um with with participants in your
research about getting consent and so
forth so trying to arrive at things that
everybody would agree on which is what
we've what we mean by Universal
um but where I think that even that
is limited
is that
um you know if you look at the workings
of an Ethics Committee and I have to put
all of my research human research
through an Ethics Committee in my
University ethics committees don't just
go through a tick box you know where
they can say well this looks ethical it
passes all the tests they sit and
discuss because it's the Nuance of you
know of the wording of your study or the
methods of your study which are gonna
you know everything's gonna turn on the
detail and it needs discussion the last
point I was going to make about
Universal ethics you know it's is it's
probably kind of impossible because
things change with time
so I can imagine that today animal
experimenting is considered to be okay
um but I can imagine in the future
there'll be a time when animal
experimentation will not be considered
okay and even more so because there are
alternatives to animal experimentation
uh you know science now has the
opportunity to to to use so-called model
systems which do not involve hurting or
sacrificing an animal to test
um for example if a drug might be useful
for a particular organ you know we can
imagine in the future that there'll be a
ban on all animal testing
so it changes with time our concepts of
what we might all agree is sitting
around a a table in an Ethics Committee
we might all agree this is ethical might
be a function of what is available and
how have attitudes changed over time so
on that note I wanted to ask the the
whole panel of course anyone feel free
to jump in with regards to what anyone
else has said about this idea of where
we derive these objective truths from I
mean obviously Massimo doesn't think
there are objective truths and Simon I
sort of get the sense you're thinking
they're more of an evolving set of what
we might call Universal truths
um so maybe Sophie Grace do you do you
have uh you know some insights for us on
where do these objective morals come
from what is the reference point if any
for you know ascertaining what they
actually are well I want to go back to
uh something that Massimo said which is
that
um if you didn't have some rules then
you wouldn't have a society at all
um so I would like to start although as
I say I am a
point of view of the universe
objectivist as well I think the way to
talk about this is not by starting there
because it's just too difficult I think
and also just about Massimo because
um Canada famously said two things fill
me with Wonder and all the more I
reflect on them one is the story happens
above and the other is the moral law
within and when Camp says that he's
drawing out a stoic theme
and the stoic theme is the contrast of
order in the universe the macrocosm with
order in the soul the microcosm and so
in stoicism these two things go hand in
hand you have the objectivity out there
the Transcendent objectivity and you
also have the objectivity that comes
from within the imminent objectivity so
I was very struck that Massimo
apparently doesn't have time for the
Transcendent objectivity but what I do
want to agree with Massimo about is this
that if we're going to discuss
objectivity then we don't need to worry
actually with respect to Simon I don't
think we need to worry about the
universal because we don't have to deal
with every moral conflict there's ever
been right now we have to deal just with
this moral conflict and that's a matter
of conversation and negotiation and I
think that when we negotiate with others
um I'm thinking the kind of approach
that Jurgen harbermass takes to ethics
it starts with dialogue it starts with
conversation and with any luck
we will be able to negotiate terms out
that we can agree to get to live
together by and I think that some of
those terms that we will negotiate our
way to will inevitably take the form of
rules I think rules will be part of what
we get if we take that imminent approach
to objectivity and we say look what can
we thrash out together how can we agree
to live together so I think one of the
basic values that we'll have is indeed
as Simon's been saying empathy I think
another is the thing I've been banging
about banging on about trust and I think
one thing that trust really needs and
this brings us back to objectivity and
Truth one thing trust really needs is
the rule do not tell lies
and when I look at the state of UK and
U.S politics and indeed Italian politics
um the attractiveness of the rule do not
tell lies especially in public life
especially if you're a journalist or a
politician don't tell lies the
attractiveness of that as a way of
getting objectivity together being able
to live together being able to negotiate
I think is is huge if only people didn't
tell lies
well but but in fact we do tell lies all
the time for good reasons I mean that
was that's one of the standard
objections about a kantian uh you know
Universal rule against lying uh the the
obvious example is well the Nazi officer
knocks in my door do I lie about him
about hiding the Jew in the basement
right so again that's another situation
where the general framework is okay
generally speaking you don't want to lie
but you need to use your judgment in a
specific case
so so whenever you've got
um refugees in your basement Massimo and
whenever the Nazis are at the door you
do tell a lie then right but then I
brought the percentage of cases what
percentage of your cases is that but
that's the case there are many other
cases where I can do the same in a more
you know sort of less dramatic situation
so then then we have to start agreeing
on when is it acceptable when it's not
and and I think it gets complicated as I
said as a general rule that's okay it's
a general sort of 10 10 10 tending to
behave that way that's okay but I want
to go back to your issue about
Transcendence and sort of universal
objectivity I think that was a little
too fast
um you can't say oh well let's set that
aside we don't want to talk about that
we want the the to talk about what we
need to do right now well yeah but what
we need to do right now is informed by
whatever transcendental view you may or
may not have so I think we do need to
talk about it and I reject the transcend
any transcendental view because I think
the morality is a human invention it's a
it's an evolutionary invention
um and that doesn't mean as I said
before that it's arbitrary that it's not
constrained by a number of of factors so
it's it's not true that anything goes
but nevertheless I reject anything that
is Transcendental yeah you're right the
ancient stoics believe in a in a
providential universe that was a living
organism but you know I have to go with
modern science uh which tells me that no
the universe is not a living organism in
that with providential powers so I do I
think that that debate is interesting I
also want to ask about to Simon because
uh this thing because I was a little
surprised about empathy as you know
there are some of your colleagues in
Psychology Paul Bloom I think for
instance at Yale who are very skeptical
of the use of empathy right and I think
they have a point because yes and but
it's natural and yes you don't want a
human being without him but that's a
psychopath
nevertheless because empathy Is So based
on on uh you know sort of a emotional
response that we have to certain
situations
um it it's easy to manipulate people
through uh through empathy it's easy to
convince yourself that you should be
doing something because you have this
gut feeling that that's the right thing
but it turns out upon reflection and
maybe you shouldn't and that is why in
in certain philosophical circles at
least there's a shift from empathy to
sympathy
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas